like every season our friendship gets
deeper on the show
Aaron craco breaks her social-media
silence in the wake of her when calls
the heart co-star Laurie locklins
College Admissions scandal the actress
took to Instagram Monday for the first
time in nearly a month to share this
photo of a blooming pink rose her
caption cryptic but heartfelt quote you
are always there for me and I always
will be
we certainly have a very deep bond now
and I think you can it's palpable I
think when you watch television and you
see the two of us you can see that
there's a genuine love that we have for
each other and she's an incredible
listener Oh a true true friend through
ups and downs just a great great person
in March Laurie was indicted and
arrested for her alleged involvement in
the scandal as a result hallmark
confirmed to ET that they cut ties with
her which means her roles in garage-sale
mysteries and when calls the heart are
over welcome to Hope Valley constable
Grant please call me Nathan oh please
call me Abigail when calls the heart is
temporarily on hiatus while the network
evaluates their creative options but in
the meantime several of the series stars
have taken to social media like Pascal
Hutton who expressed her gratitude for
everyone's patience and promised we will
be back on the air and in your home soon
Paul Green also thanked the fans writing
on Twitter
love you all thanks for the amazing love
and support through this tough spot
remember love and tenderness win I do
get very emotional about our show I'm
really proud of our show how far we've
come
[Music]